[Music]
foreign
so I thought today it would be really
useful to do a quick review of some
basic calculus starting with the
derivative so we're going to be building
up to differential equations uh how
systems change in time and so
understanding the derivative is a really
key piece of that okay and most of us
have seen the derivative before we've
learned about this in Calculus class so
I'm just going to give a quick refresher
here where we have some function f of
some independent variable X so we're
going to say that we have an independent
variable X on the x-axis and then we
have some function f of x on the y-axis
maybe I will draw this as
just some curve
and we are going to define the
derivative as the rate of change of this
function f of x kind of how much this
function changes in this direction as I
vary the X Direction okay so I'm going
to write this down then we're going to
draw a picture then I'm going to write
out the math so you're going to get
words picture math okay so the
derivative is the rate of change
the rate of change
of our function of a function
uh f of x
with respect and I'll tell you what all
these words mean with respect respect
r-e-s-p-e-c-t to
an independent variable
independent variable
X
okay good so what this means is
literally how much F changes when I
change x a little bit so if I move x a
little bit to the right does f go up or
down and does it go up or down by a lot
or a little okay pretty simple idea now
why we would care about this rate of
change of our function f with respect to
to some variable X that it depends on
well because of physics for one usually
this kind of is introduced in the
context of physics where maybe you have
something like you know a cannonball
being shot out of a cannon and you want
to understand for example what is the
rate of vertical climb as The Cannonball
moves in the horizontal Direction X in
that case f of x would be kind of its
vertical position as a function of its
horizontal position X so that's one
example where you'd want to compute the
rate of change or the rate of climb of
this ballistic Cannonball as a function
of x
um I'll come back to some other examples
in a little bit
and so the derivative is the rate of
change or how fast this function f of x
changes when we vary or change the
independent variable X the the variable
that F depends on so f is a function
that depends on x
and so the way we draw this as a picture
so this is in words rate of change the
picture of this is that at some position
let's call this you know this is some X
position then this derivative is
essentially going to be the slope of the
tangent line to this function at that
point x so I'll try to draw this let's
see if I can do a reasonable job here
okay so that's a line that is tangent
that's kind of locally in the same
direction as my function f at that exact
point x and the slope of that line
literally kind of how much that line
goes up for every amount it goes over
the sometimes this is called in in a
Calculus class the rise over the run the
the Delta F given a Delta x a little
change in F given a change in X those
are all ways you've heard this and that
of course is the slope that's the
definition of the slope of this tangent
line it's how much it goes up for every
bit it goes over how much f of x changes
for every little change in X okay so
these words mean the same thing as this
picture
now what you can do practically speaking
uh is one way that we might approximate
this derivative of this function or the
rate of change of f versus X is we might
take two points that are kind of nearby
so X and then maybe X plus a little
teeny Delta X and in math classes in my
class usually when you see a little
Delta that means a small a small
perturbation so X Plus Delta X just
means X plus a little bit you know to
the right or to the left okay so I take
my point x and my point x a little bit
to the right let's just write that here
this is f of this is f of x plus Delta X
this point here maybe make this in pink
is going to be f of x and so you can at
least apply approximate the derivative
by the slope of the line that connects
these two points f at X and F at X Plus
Delta X so I'll draw that line here
let's hope I can do this
not too badly
okay that's not too bad
and you can see that my my yellow line
here that is kind of an approximation is
not terrible and also as I make this
Delta X smaller and smaller as I bring
these two points together this will get
closer and closer and closer to that
true tangent line in pink okay so the
slope of this yellow line is approximate
this approximate tangent line here is an
approximation of my derivative
so what I'm going to write down is I'm
going to write down that the derivative
the you know derivative of my function f
with respect to X that's literally what
these symbols mean is the rate of change
of f with respect to X as I vary X how
much does f change that's going to be
approximately equal
to the slope of this yellow line which
if I go back to my kind of high school
algebra the slope of this yellow line is
going to be how much F varies which is f
of x plus Delta X
minus f of x
and divided by so that's the rise that's
how much F changed and we divide that by
how much X changed divided by an X here
changed
by Delta X so all of this divided by
Delta X that is the slope of this uh
this yellow line here and like I said
before
as I make Delta X smaller and smaller
and smaller so I bring these points
closer and closer and closer together
this this approximate tangent line gets
closer and closer and closer to that
true pink tangent line that is the slope
of which is the actual exact derivative
so not the approximate derivative but
the exact derivative is the slope of
this pink line the tangent line exactly
at that point x and my approximation
gets better and better and better as
this Delta X goes to zero as it gets
smaller and smaller and these points get
closer and closer you can see this line
kind of converging and we'll eventually
do this on a computer and I'll show you
how this gets closer and closer so this
is the key Innovation that Newton and
leibniz introduced and they changed the
world ever since it blew everyone's mind
at the time is that we can take the
limit
as Delta X goes to zero we can actually
compute we can calculate what this limit
is and get a function out some some
expression and now this is no longer
approximate this is exact now we have
the exact expression for the derivative
DF DX the rate of change of f with
respect to X is the limit of this
expression as I take Delta X to Zero as
I as I limit this line as I limit these
two points to be closer and closer and
closer I slide this yellow Point towards
this this pink point then my
approximation gets better and better and
better until I get the exact derivative
and so that's the definition of the
derivative this is the mathematical
definition
of the derivative okay is this limit as
Delta X goes to zero of f of x plus
Delta x f at a neighboring point at some
you know X plus a little Delta x minus F
at x divided by Delta X okay now
in this class on you know differential
equations and how to model the world
with you know uh with differential
equations I'm actually going to show you
a lot of computational techniques how
you actually compute these things you
know you know on your computer how you
approximate derivatives and and uh the
rates of change of systems and in that
case often we're going to drop this
limit we're going to actually use a
finite Delta X to approximate our
derivatives and so we are going to
accrue a little bit of error we're going
to accumulate a little bit of error
every time we don't take this limit as
Delta X goes to zero but a ton of
computational schemes for numerical
integration and numerical
differentiation are essentially built on
this formula where you just drop this
Assumption of taking
uh the limit as as Delta X goes to zero
okay so we'll do a lot of that uh later
on when we you know approximate
derivatives numerically and you might
think well well okay I could probably
have done a better job of getting a
slope of this yellow line Maybe by
taking one point to the right of X and
one point to the left of X and finding
the slope between those two uh those two
points that's absolutely possible it
won't give you any different answer when
you take the limit as Delta X goes to
zero this is exactly true when you take
the limit as Delta X goes to zero but
for a finite non-zero Delta X there are
more accurate ways of approximating this
pink line so for example instead of just
add Point f of x and x plus Delta X I
could try f of x plus Delta X and f of x
minus Delta X and maybe that's going to
give me a better approximation in fact
we will show in a few weeks that that is
you know provably more accurate for some
functions okay so this is the derivative
in words in a geometric picture and in
math
so now let's just do some examples uh
we'll we'll compute the derivative of
some functions I'll show you uh the
power law and the chain rule which are
two of the absolute most important uh
kind of outfalls of the derivative
they're the two most useful kind of uh
tricks that we use to compute the
derivatives of most functions and then
in a future lecture we're going to go
all the way into the Taylor series so
we're going to approximate functions
using a higher and higher order
derivatives this Taylor series expansion
which is again kind of built on this
basic idea here okay and I'll point out
you know a lot of my emphasis in this uh
well in the class that you probably
brought you here is thinking about
differential equations so something like
you know I have some state of a system X
and I'm going to take its derivative
with respect to time and maybe that's
some function
of X so this differential equation I
need to be able to approximate this
derivative and understand it so in this
case uh
be my function
and X varies in T So X would be my
function T would be my independent
variable in that case that's what I mean
by the the derivative of x with respect
to T
so I might take the derivative of f of x
with respect to X I might take the
derivative of x of t with respect to T
and I want you to be comfortable that I
can you know if I have some function
that varies with some other variable I
can take the derivative of that function
with respect to that variable so here x
might be the position with respect to
time and if I take the derivative of
that position with respect to time that
would be physically the velocity okay
and so I can I can take that derivative
as well
good
okay uh so how about we do an example
let's say
um
let's just start off easy let's do
something like x squared okay so we're
going to do uh the derivative of x
squared that's my function
um so let me write this out explicitly f
of x equals x squared okay and so the
derivative of f with respect to X
the derivative of f with respect to X we
know you know like most of you just
remember that the derivative of x
squared is 2x okay so I'm going to use
this formula and show that what we get
is 2x okay so dfdx we know that this is
equal to the Limit
as Delta X goes to zero of my function
at X Plus Delta X so that is literally X
Plus Delta x squared minus my function
evaluated at X that's literally just x
squared divided by Delta X
so this is a pretty easy example all I
have to do is expand this out you know X
Plus Delta x squared minus x squared
divided by Delta X and then take the
limit
so this is like our warm-up problem
uh okay so X Plus Delta x squared is x
squared plus 2 x Delta X Plus Delta x
squared that's this
minus x squared
that whole thing divided by Delta X okay
so now I'm going to switch colors just
to keep it interesting
and now the limit as Delta X goes to
zero okay so my X squareds cancel
and I'm left with 2 x Delta X
I'm just going to say that's divided by
Delta X
plus Delta x squared divided by Delta X
okay this is pretty easy so again
these Delta X's cancel
these Delta X's cancel and this becomes
just
Delta X
and so now I finally have the limit as
Delta X goes to 0 of 2x
plus Delta X
and of course as Delta X goes to zero
Delta X goes to zero and so this just
equals two x
so it's really easy to just kind of
confirm your intuition that the
derivative of x squared is 2x by
actually just plugging in this function
into this expression and going through
the math okay pretty pretty simple
and so we're going to do this exact same
idea but now instead of f of x equals x
squared we're going to do x to the nth
power and we're going to derive the uh
the power law for how to take the
derivative of an arbitrary nth order
power of X okay so that's what I'm going
to do now
sometimes I fast forward when I'm
erasing
okay that wasn't too bad
and so now what we're going to do is
we're going to take the derivative of an
arbitrary function f of x equals x to
the nth power n is an integer like two
three four five six seven I guess it
doesn't even have to be an integer it
could be well let's assume it's an
integer for now
uh and we're going to do the exact same
thing just work through so again we know
uh like we know
we have inside Knowledge from our you
know Calculus class that we probably
took but we might not remember that uh
DF DX equals n times x to the N minus
one this is the rule that we're going to
try to derive right now and this is a
super important Point um I always like
to kind of point out to my students you
know I took calculus ages ago and I've
forgotten probably more than I remember
I'll be perfectly honest with you um you
know I learned a ton of calculus I loved
calculus and you know when you don't use
it you forget it and so there's a ton of
stuff I forgot but almost all of
calculus is very intuitive and it's
based on first principles you know the
the first principles of trying to
understand how things change with
respect to other things and so what I
really want to impart on you is not just
formulas to remember but what are the
absolute first principles that if you
remember those you can derive all the
formulas again when you forget them okay
so maybe you don't remember the power
law or the chain rule of course you can
derive those from this basic first
principles so that's kind of why I'm
showing you this is first off just to
get practice doing it but also to remind
you that you can kind of derive all of
this from scratch okay so now we're just
going to do this derivative same thing
we're going to say that um
dfdx equals we know that this is the
limit
um I'm going to drop my limit until the
very end because it drives me crazy
writing limit limit every time so we're
just going to say we know that we're
going to take the limit as Delta X goes
to zero but for now I'm just going to
say this is approximately equal
to f of x plus Delta x minus f of x
divided by Delta X
and so I'm going to literally plug in X
Plus Delta X to x to the power n
so this is X Plus Delta x to the power n
minus x to the power n divided by Delta
X
and when I'm giving this class live I
always ask my students you know how do I
compute X Plus Delta x to the power n
does anyone remember
and you might remember that Blaze Pascal
coolest name ever Blaze uh you know
wrote down this um
what's it called Pascal's triangle for
the binomial expansion for a plus b to
the power n and kind of what all the
coefficients of those terms are so you
can kind of just go Google you know
Pascal's triangle for binomial expansion
and you'll find that X Plus Delta x to
the power n actually has a really simple
expression it's a x to the power n
Plus
n
x to the power n minus 1 times a Delta X
plus n times n minus 1 over 2 x to the
power n minus 2 Delta x squared plus dot
dot dot
um you know eventually I'm going to get
a Delta x to the power n something like
that okay this is this whole expression
here I'm just going to put this in
parentheses this is my X Plus Delta x to
the power n
okay you can just refresh yourself on
you know Pascal's triangle for this
expansion so we're going to take this
minus x to the power n all of that
divided by Delta X
and you can already see what's going to
happen I think is that you know these
really high power Delta x to the N
divided by Delta X when I take the limit
as Delta X goes to zero you know this is
going to be Delta x to the N minus 1.
that Delta x to the N minus 1 is going
to go to zero so anything with a Delta X
left over after I divide my Delta X is
going to go to zero when I take the
limit so only like one of these terms is
going to is going to pop out probably
this term that I see right there
okay so we're going to cancel our x to
the ends I'm going to divide my Delta X
through all of these terms just to make
my life easier this is going to equal
now
n x to the N minus 1. I divide that
Delta X through
plus n and minus 1 over 2 x to the N
minus 2 Delta x squared over Delta X is
just Delta X
plus and I'm just going to say dot dot
dot order
Delta x squared this order Delta x
squared means every term to the right
that I'm not writing down because I'm
lazy has power Delta x squared or higher
so here I canceled out my Delta X and I
got a Delta X you know Delta x squared
over Delta X I had one Delta X remaining
the next term is a Delta X cubed over
Delta X that would be a Delta x squared
remaining then Delta x to the fourth
over Delta X is a Delta X cubed
remaining so all of the terms I'm too
lazy to write down have at least Delta x
squared or higher
so now here is where I'm going to say
okay now if I take the limit as Delta X
goes to 0 of this whole expression all
of this expression
the only term that doesn't have a Delta
X anything with multiplying a Delta X is
going to go to zero here the only term
that doesn't have a Delta X is this
first term here all of these other terms
go to zero so the only thing left after
I take my limit is as I make my Delta X
teeny tiny as I limit this point to this
point and I get the actual exact
derivative the only term left is n times
x to the power n minus 1. which is
exactly what we thought we would get and
this is called the power law literally
what is the derivative of a power of x
okay good so just rehashing what you
already know and showing that it's
really easy to go from first principles
to this very powerful General expression
so now you can take the derivative of
any polynomial in X good you could do
this for sine of x for cosine of x for e
to the X for log of x you could plug
those into this formula go back through
you know some of those tricks that you
remember from algebra and trigonometry
and you could derive the derivative of
sine is cosine and the derivative of
cosine is minus sine and the derivative
of e to the x is e to the X and things
like that okay derivative of log of x is
1 over X you can do all of those things
using the simple property from first
principles okay last thing I'm going to
show you is even more important than the
power lot it is the chain rule probably
the most important thing I'm going to
erase this and then do that
okay uh the chain rule is probably the
most useful uh besides the actual
definition of the derivative probably
the most useful piece that we'll use
over and over and over again so I'm just
going to write it down the chain rule
and the chain rule allows us to take the
derivative of these kind of big
composite functions where some function
f of another function G I'll write this
down so if we have let's say we have two
functions
two functions
f of x and G of X then we can take the
derivative d d X
of f of G of X I literally you know if I
have some point x I run it through G and
whatever that number is I run that
through F that's what F of G of X means
and the derivative of f of G of x
I'll give you an example in a minute
this is going to be the derivative of f
with respect to X
that this derivative so if it was you
know x squared this would be 2x so that
function
of G of x
times
the derivative of G with respect to X
okay evaluated at X
so this is a very very very useful
formula because you know I know how to
take the derivatives of
polynomials now I can probably remind
myself how to take the derivative of
trigonometric functions Sines and
cosines and tangents and things like
that but what if I want to take the
derivative of sine of x cubed or X you
know you know sine of x quantity cubed I
would have to use this chain Rule and so
this expresses a much broader class of
functions that are kind of you know one
function of another function
in shorthand sometimes we write this as
you know F Prime
of G of x times G Prime of X where here
Prime just means you know literally F
Prime of X is defined as DF
DX that function the derivative of my
function f with respect to X and that
function is going to be evaluated at
that point
X so it's literally the slope of F at
that point x that's just what F Prime of
X means that's the derivative and so the
chain rule the derivative of f of G of X
is the derivative of f evaluated at G of
x times the derivative of G evaluated at
X and you can derive this in the exact
same way using first principles using
this definition in fact I think that's a
really good exercise is to like take
this plug it in here and start working
out why it would actually give you this
expression but I'll just give you a
really simple example and then we'll end
the lecture okay this is a review of
calculus this is not you know a whole
course on calculus so I'm just reminding
you of things that you already know this
chain rule is super important uh so
let's say uh let us say
that you know f of x equals okay what do
I want to do here I want to make f of x
equal to sine of x
I like the sine function and let's say G
of x equals X cubed okay
so this will make it a lot more uh make
a lot more sense because this is just a
bunch of math gobbledygook if you're not
familiar with what it means but this
will make a lot more sense when I
actually write this out
G of x f of G of X literally means I
take G of X and I plug it in wherever I
see an X in my f of x expression so I
take this and I plug it in here
so F of G of X is literally just sine
of X cubed
it's you know sine of G of X sine of x
cubed so this is just another function
of X it's a Harrier function that either
of these because it's kind of a
composition so you can get bigger
battery functions by doing F of G for
two simple functions
competitive of this is really really
easy to compute so the derivative d d x
of f of G of x
is just equal to again the derivative of
f with respect so the derivative of sine
is cosine so it's cosine
evaluated at G of X meaning evaluated at
X cubed
so derivative of f is just cosine and
it's F Prime of G of X of X cubed so
cosine of x cubed times the derivative
of G of X of X cubed is 3x squared so
that's three
x squared so this is the derivative I
probably shouldn't have skipped a skip I
probably should have written cos x cubed
times 3 x squared and then move my 3 out
okay I just did it but this is how you
compute the derivative really really
simple so I can compute the derivative
of really nasty functions like sine of x
cubed I say well okay sine of x cubed is
just F being sine and X cubed being G
and then I use the chain rule for
derivative of f of G of X and I get a
really simple expression out okay so so
this is just a quick review of the
derivative it's the rate of change of a
function with respect to its independent
variable so it could be some function f
of x how much does f change as I vary X
you can have this simple geometric
picture in words or in math and you can
use that first principle basic idea to
kind of get these really powerful rules
out that allow you to take the
derivative of almost any function
anything else I want to tell you
that's pretty much it you know in the
future we're going to be approximating
these things you know now not taking the
limit as Delta X goes to zero and there
will be some error but that's how we do
it on a computer because your computer
doesn't know how to take the limit as
Delta X goes to zero without you telling
it how to okay uh thanks for listening
and we're gonna you know hopefully this
will help you build up now into things
like differential equations okay thanks
foreign
[Music]